nous devons à présent choisir mon
successeur il n'ya qu'un homme que
l'opposition acceptera
il représente une chose et une seule lui
même
[Musique]
pourquoi ai-je été contraint de faire
appel à churchill son bilan est une
catastrophe
notre leur thé vraie qualité ton absence
de vanité oui ma volonté de faire tomber
les murs
[Musique]
votre majesté il est de mon devoir de
vous inviter à prendre le poste de
premier ministre du royaume uni
[Musique]
je m'adresse à vous pour la première
fois en tant que premier ministre
les allemands ou d'encercler 60 division
britannique et française nous allons
assister à l'effondrement de l'europe de
l'ouest dans les prochains jours combien
de temps tiendront ils si nous ne les
secourons pas peut-être deux jours il
faudra un miracle pour sortir nos
troupes de là
tu porte tout le poids du monde sur tes
épaules nous encourons défaite terrestre
certainement la destruction de notre
armée est une invasion imminente
nous devons entamer des pourparlers de
caen comprendrez-vous la leçon on ne
peut pas discuter avec un tigre
quand on a la tête entre ses deux matois
sottise
le seul problème c'est que si vous
essayez de mater rendre quand je suis en
train de vous interrompre nous avons
devant nous nombreux et de longs mois de
lutte et de souffrance
même si nombre de grands des vieilles
nations sont tombés sous l'emprise du
régime nazi
nous défendrons notre ville
quel que soit le prix à payer
nous battrons sur les plages nous nous
battrons sur les terrains d'aviation de
nous battrons dans les sols et dans les
rues
nous nous battrons dans les collines
nous ne nous rendons sa mère
tu as sans victoire il ne peut y avoir
de sion